you see that Waffle House girl you did
The Waffle House girl Wildflower is one
of the best fighting rings I've ever
seen I haven't seen that yet wait so is
is there business model sustainable
though Waffle House it's crushing him
[Music]
hi Nick educate us on the pfl oh the pfl
is a MMA League organization and they're
big is a [ __ ] fighting League
got him
what's cool about the pfl is that unlike
the UFC they do a tournament style for
each weight Division and the winner of
the tournament bracket wins a million
dollars at the end oh and whoa whoa they
pay their buyers the tournament no it's
over like a couple like
a couple months maybe it's like a last
man same night would be crazy old school
mmas were like that is it last man
standing style kinda but it's like so so
if you but it's over time oh you have
like four fights to the title and then
if you win the title you get a million
dollars but then they it's cool because
they restructured in a way where they
pay their fighters to be able to have a
life and be able to compete for the
million dollars and then like if you win
by like a knockout you get like four
points and that puts you up at the top
of the bracket if you win by decision
you get like two points or some [ __ ]
that's the way it works out good the way
it works out is the guys who get
finishes the guys that do really well
they get incentivized really winning
you're doing better you get the top of
the seed clear Knockouts not my decision
and a lot of the UFC guys that got cut
from the UFC have gone to the pfl and
won championships there and won millions
of dollars so it's like a cool thing
where it's like oh if you're talking
about fighter pay it is really cool to
see an organization that is paying their
Fighters nothing pissed me off more
recently than watching that Patty the
Baddie fight oh yeah and hearing him
like basically Donald Trump his way into
into trying to sell the crowd that it
was a great fight he's like Fight The
Noise Okay fight to the [ __ ] noise
and I'm like bro you won by decision and
everyone thought you lost yeah he did
with us
fight to the [ __ ] noise
who who runs the pfl like who started it
uh I'm not sure I'm not sure I think it
was a guy named Ray cepho because he was
oh yeah I think I think he's one of the
president kiss boxing Legend and K1
before it used to be called World Series
of fighting and then I think they
restructured the company into this pfl
it was uh founded by venture capitalist
Don Davis
wow wow that is way off I was like damn
I didn't know business business Acumen
it was so crazy Ray steffo might have
been like the Dana White actually oh
okay okay you can bring them all
together yeah yeah because he's a Legend
um what's also mentioned here is
I was like really is that check nobody
fights for a million dollars and
everything Nick just says wait wait what
what does pfl stand for professional
fighter uh [ __ ] Fighters League
professionals
too late Paul and the pfl have
co-created a pay-per-view division
called called pfl ppv super Jake Paul
right yeah super fight I saw he just got
signed to it which is a huge deal it's a
huge deal uh and that is a division that
guarantees Fighters will receive 50 of
revenue from its events 50 that's a ton
well when Jake Paul was talking [ __ ] to
Dana White about that stuff totally yeah
so now he's putting his money over his
mouth and this is this is the perfect
league for him to like combine with to
like talk [ __ ] to Dana White whoa pretty
good so Paul is the first fighter sign
or to talk to another org about and now
everybody's like well why don't you
fight MMA fight MMA because an aspirin's
there yep oh is he yeah he he's part of
pfl now yeah do you guys think that Dana
White's gonna give his wife a shot at
the title the slap Championship yeah
on TBS I mean not on TBS anymore but
yeah so yeah Paul's the first fighter
signed to the new division he doesn't
have a match scheduled but plans to
compete in 2023 he says quote I've
proven myself in and out of the boxing
ring and now I am going to do the same
in MMA and there's no limit to the
positive impact I can have on the sport
wow that's pretty gangster dude I like
that it's pretty cool the path piece
Paving is pretty gangster everything did
you guys hear that he's also the
communications director for the
Cleveland Browns no way Jake Paul
we got a knock and it's not food you
sure I know it's not food why it's it's
your wife
hey guys we have a special guest
no come on come inside just real quick
just say hi just say hi what the hell
dude
[Music]
what
the heck wait how is this a thing she's
bringing your phone
she brought your phone dude I was taking
this [ __ ] earlier she's like she's like
what's she's like I'm trying to bring
the phone what's happening that's so
nice because I didn't even happy New
Year wow thanks for doing that that's
really cool hi nice to meet you
yeah she's never met yeah that's right
wow
you wasn't a drink protein shakes you
want some chicken you want to sit down
you want to get in the hot sauce
hey you want to get in the hot scene
thanks for bringing my phone that's cool
yeah you kept getting scam calls I was
like oh
you want to call them back thanks for
not signing up to anything
wow that's that is so sweet that's
awesome that's love dude thank you you
wanna go say butter I didn't even ask
you yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
dude that was the most thoughtful thing
I've ever seen my phone I didn't even
like say anything to her tip would never
bring my phone dude she would throw in
the [ __ ] trash
the [ __ ] garbage disposal dude none
of them watch this show either all right
so back to the [ __ ] thing yeah oh yeah
yeah [ __ ] Fighters League um Paul and
the pfl said they want to create a
fighter first culture with the new 50 50
Revenue partnership model for all
Pay-Per-View fights there Revenue split
is much better than what talent makes in
the UFC where Fighters reportedly earn
less than 20 percent of gross revenue
which is true it's very true
and the only guys that make all the good
money in the UFC are probably the
biggest stars the Stars yeah so it's
still like regardless of your record
it's just if you draw in the seats
you're gonna get paid if you get the
pay-per-view logistically that also kind
of makes sense like you can't pay more
than like what is you know
what are you laughing at
huh what are you laughing at keep going
I'll tell you later I want to do derail
think about Ryan I mean kissing girls
right now oh boy is that funny funny
so yeah also for the announcement Paul
has been appointed quote head of fighter
advocacy and said he will continue to
work towards a business model that
benefits Fighters quote I invite all top
MMA fighters both men and women to join
the pfl and get a Payday like they've
never had before see that's a really
good incentive now there's competition
in the marketplace with Fighters where
they might be like hey once my contract
is up I'm gonna go to the pfl like Nate
Diaz his contract was up in the U.S yeah
where is like pfl like compared to like
UFC are we talking like NFL XFL are we
talking kind of NBA WNBA like like pfl I
think in a lot of people's eyes MMA fans
that are like casual they kind of really
don't know it exists but PJ masks
probably yeah not even it's probably
it's probably like like a like so this
is what Shaquille O'Neal is like no
Reebok military is no Nike I'm gonna go
to Payless ShoeSource there's like UFC
Bellator yeah PS1
yeah UFC won Bellator and then maybe pfl
with pfl is on ESPN
how long has pfl's been around
a couple years and then and then wipe
out
you see that Waffle House girl you did
the [ __ ] Waffle House girls one of
the best fighting rings I've ever seen I
haven't seen that yet which so is is
there business model sustainable though
Waffle House it's crushing everybody
and then when you get into Waffle House
you hear it's time
once you get between those four walls
dude you don't know what's gonna happen
that's the tough part it's hard to say
because that's what Dana White always
says where he's like if you guys try to
run this business you'll see why it's
the way it is right right so who knows I
mean none of them have been as long
around as long as the UFC and I think
the way he does it it's like you kind of
have to prove yourself and make yourself
a mini star and then he'll give you a
launch pad which is why the stars make
hella money but in the beginning
people get like 10 G's maybe a 520 G's a
fight and you're not you're not even
showing on pay-per-view so Patty the
Baddie right he's a star he's a star he
probably gets a lot of pay-per-view
numbers for when every time he fights
um but his last contract was like 12 and
12. so meaning 12 000 to show to fight
and then 12 000 to win for someone who
is
as a big of a star as he is 24K is like
that's how much you get to fight
somebody in the case does boxing pay
better because the audience size is
bigger because that's the only thing
that makes sense for me where like uh
like football right the audience size is
massive even though if it's just the us
watching it it's hard to compare because
if you're up and coming like journeyman
boxer you're making like a thousand
dollars a fight yeah so it depends on
who you're comparing are you comparing
like star with stars yeah start with
star middle are you like a right the
Stars will not make as much as boxers
and I'm not even saying like people who
would throw their own uh fights like
Mayweather I'm just talking about like
guys that show up and get paid they're
even getting way more than like a UFC
fighter is it because of how long it's
been around like TV versus YouTube or
like I don't really get it it's
equalizing now I don't know if box if
the top boxers are getting paydays like
the way Mayweather used to yeah well
there's something to the waiting the
contracts too because like MLB they'll
pay people like four million dollars
[ __ ] yeah and then they they could get
injured and still get paid and then the
contracts are really good for baseball
versus like football you if you're
injured you're out you don't get paid
and the average is like 500
um yeah half a million dollars like the
average player gets that so the The
Benchwarmers getting a [ __ ] ton of money
in baseball is it because it's been
around so [ __ ] long I think so the
contract's way more sick the contracts
are long though in baseball you're
talking about like 10 12-year contracts
sometimes but like with UFC or or
fighting it's like that person might not
last till the next fight and that's the
big thing the the person could even get
injured in training camp and he's out
the next fight but didn't Patty the
baddie sign something with like bar
stool and a couple other places so like
six or seven figure deals so that
supplements his income and then what he
gets from the fight is like 24 G's but
then he gets a bunch of other [ __ ] for
being like a big name so apparently
there's a lot of controversy with uh era
Hawaii is like the big MMA journalist
he's he's great but he was talking about
specifically Patty the baddie's manager
works for this company called um it's
like the Irish UFC the cage Warriors oh
and they are like Conor came up yeah
that's where Conor came from they are
the feeder system to the UFC so because
he is the manager of this promotion this
fight promotion of cage Warriors and
he's the manager of Patty the Baddie
there's a lot of controversy saying that
like oh he's just kind of using you to
get a really low deal for Patty the
Baddie but the UFC gets all the benefit
because he's a massive star and they get
to benefit way more from how many eyes
he brings to the show but then Patty the
Baddie don't care because he's got bar
stool Barstool is paying him probably
like six seven figures is to be a
sponsored athlete so they're taking care
of him but if he didn't have that I
wonder what he would feel like if he was
getting paid 24K with all the eyes he's
getting interesting yeah that's the
weird dilemma like he's in a really
special place you know I I could see how
a model with pfl with 50 50 Revenue
split towards the fighters could still
make sense from a business model I mean
it's Revenue Spirit right so it's like
it's it's in their actual net earnings
you get a guy like Jake Paul to bring
all the eyes to this promotion now
you're now you're cooking with some
fight 50 of whatever Jake Paul is going
to bring is probably still a heat you
know what I mean because there's some
UFC fighters that are like you know I
think Jake Paul's a [ __ ] [ __ ] but
I like what he's doing you know like is
it true though that that Jake Paul and
Logan Paul bring the eyes but not the
money in terms of people paying for
pay-per-view see I think because the
product of the boxing matches are just
kind of like hit or miss it depends on
who the who the B side is Right
obviously we know Jake Paul is the a
side but the last pay-per-view they did
was who do fight last uh Anderson Silva
yeah apparently Andrew Silva's
Pay-Per-View fight like didn't really do
kind of tank it kind of Tanked right but
I think it's because it's Anderson Silva
and it's like he may not be as
mainstream as like I don't know who and
the novelty kind of wore off a little
bit yeah and he's a 45 year old dude
it's like people are kind of getting
sick of Jake Paul anyway but this brings
a whole new light to it especially if
he's gonna fight him man isn't it like
like because I don't know what I'm
looking at when I'm watching UFC fights
for example like I just see a lot of
[ __ ] dudes hugging and stuff but and
like the Jujitsu stuff I don't know like
but you guys but you guys are fans of it
right and you know what you're looking
at so like is it like maybe the mashup
like for me I'm like oh [ __ ] the Bills
versus the Bengals that's two of the
best teams like in the NFL right now I
can't wait to watch that right but then
like for you guys it's like Jake Paul
versus some clown like or or even Silva
It's like that is not even a a
competition I would rather do something
else tonight yeah I think what it is
it's a lot of that and I think that's
what the UFC does really well is their
marketing and their storytelling that's
what they're best at so they I think
that's why they will continue to crush
because if you watch enough of their
like UFC inside access or even their
commercials two people you never heard
of all of a sudden you're personally
invested yeah yeah whereas Jake Paul and
Anderson Silva they technically have an
insane storyline there but it's just hey
I'm gonna fight Anderson Silva hey I'm
gonna fight Jack Paul and then they're
just repeating that rather than having
like a really good story to tell like if
that was a UFC fight it would blow like
all the seasons narrative would be like
but also too for the UFC they have a
really strong schedule of fights that
they put on all year round so if the
fight's gonna happen in August you're
already hearing about it in [ __ ] June
and may yeah they're pumping that [ __ ]
up and they're like yo so it's always in
the back of your mind and then you
always have something to look forward to
and so it's like a steady drip of like
really insane but even like the the drip
of advertising that I hear about UFC
stuff it's like the best versus the best
right the heavyweight versus the
heavyweight there's such a huge like
anticipation for that because it's like
[ __ ] Unstoppable force and movable
object and like it's crazy but like with
Jake Paul versus Silva it's like it's
like a bug versus a boot it's like who
like you're not
you know what I mean like I'd watch that
but like you know what I mean like when
I hear about that I'm just not jazzed
for that it's like that's also because I
think it's mainly for Jake Paul's fans
yeah that follow him for him so if
that's not sold well to them I think
that's why the numbers taint whereas I
think when when anyone wants to do a
fight for the first time all your fans
are like oh [ __ ] that's [ __ ] tight
that's crazy but if you do it like eight
times and it just seems like the same
gimmick they're like I don't want to
watch anymore it's the same thing I
always felt like it was because the Paul
Brothers have such young fans that are
more Savvy to just hack the [ __ ]
thing I think that's it too that too
good point like if you're just a kid you
probably know how to get it and you
don't give a [ __ ] but we'll just get in
the free download link older people are
more like hassle-free and they're like
I'll just pay for it dude they know how
to click the ads too they're like they
know how to x out the ads in the right
sequence yeah it's impressive it's
really good they can get the X like
right in the middle of the Cross whereas
like idiots like me I click it and I'm
like oh no it's fireworks down like I'll
just pay for it I'm like I don't want to
get a virus yeah
[Music]
[Music]